Hey,
what's going on it's Bill Burr?
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast and
just checking in on you,
seeing how your week's going.
Oh,
happy Valentine's Day to you.
Happy Valentine's Day to you.
Boop,
boop,
boop.
Happy Valentine's Day dear lady.
The fees.
Why don't want to you brave strong warriors.
Pick up the check.
You fucking tightwads.
You know I was watching TV the other day cause I'm not a big reader,
you know,
unless it's got a lot of pictures and they sound out the words for me.
And there was this woman on TV,
right?
One of these daytime talk shows us some shit.
She was just like Happy Valentine's Day week guy.
I fell.
I think we should celebrate that week.
It's a week of love.
It's just like how much free shit are you trying to get and stop acting like
you're celebrating love.
You're not.
You're celebrating you.
Yes.
Selfish.
Why is she a whore bill?
Cause she's on television with too much makeup.
All right.
I mean Jesus Christ,
why aren't you just out there walking the block?
Um,
Oh man,
I'm in a grumpy ass fucking mood cause I want to go to
B to the motherfucking Ed.
I want to go to bed bitches.
I don't know why I'm talking like a fucking old white housewife right now who
watched a hip hop video,
but I am
motherfuckers.
Um,
I uh,
yeah,
I want to go to bed,
but I got to go on and I got to go run my hour.
I got to go run it cause I'm doing the special soon I've got to hit the con
comedy gym and all I want to do is try out my new fucking ideas.
Right?
That's what I want to do.
But I can't,
I gotta fucking dude.
I gotta I gotta be,
I gotta be like,
you know
militant about it.
I know it's weird.
What I have to do is do my new ideas and then start with a joke.
I'm going to fucking maybe start with and then run the fucking shit and then in
the end I'm not going to do it.
I just need to be onstage talking.
That's all I need to do.
Okay.
I don't know how these fucking people do it,
where they write the whole thing out,
have the whole thing memorized or whatever.
Um,
I dunno if it's on lazy or maybe that's not how my brain works.
I have no fucking idea.
All I know is I'm running it tonight and then that's it.
Then I'm coming home and going to bed and then a buck and waking up the next
day.
I got it.
Table read for F is for family episode four.
Fucking season has been great so far.
We got some new writers and they're crushing it.
And um,
I don't know.
We're almost next week.
Next week we'll do four oh five maybe right there.
Then we halfway through the season already.
And now
will,
you're thinking,
well shit,
Bill,
what's it going to come out in June?
Oh,
I mean just halfway through.
Just the first initial writing of it.
Well,
how does it work,
Bill?
What would you like to know?
How it works in case?
So you write the fucking thing,
right?
And as you're writing the episodes,
they come back with something that's known as an animatic.
Now an animatic is basically,
it's just basically black and white sketched.
And they're like,
well,
this is how we're going to draw what you wrote.
Does this look good?
And Mobility,
like we like this,
don't have that chair there.
Have him stand up,
have him move his arm like this up and down when he says,
what the fuck is going on in here?
Right.
You do that and then it comes back,
it's a little more drawn in,
a little more color,
you know,
that's how it goes just like that.
But we're in the fourth season so they know what we like,
we know what they like.
So it moved like last season moves along quickly.
So I'm,
I'm hoping we can get this fucker done,
um,
as soon as possible.
So,
uh,
anyways,
um,
and I'm going to take my lady out for fucking Valentine's Day.
That's what I'm going to do.
And I'm going to try to be a nice guy and try not to get into a fight.
Try not to have any appeared yet.
MMM.
Yeah.
I,
you know what,
I'm,
I'm doing so much shit right now that I want to fucking go off on,
but I can't go off on it because other people's lives will be affected.
You know what?
Are you talking about?
Some top secret shit built?
No,
I'm not.
I'm just talking about,
you know,
I dunno.
Just bullshit in my fucking life.
Like,
uh,
you would never know it,
but I am not in a good mood right now.
All right.
I'm not in a good fucking mood,
but I gotta do this.
I have a responsibility to you.
Okay.
I answered the call 12 years ago to start podcasting.
The same way somebody answers the call to defend the freedom of this country.
All right?
Now,
God dammit.
If white women in this country can somehow enjoy white privilege and then yet
also make themselves victims than God dammit,
I can put myself on the same level as someone who's fighting,
you know,
what are they saying?
They're doing it.
Fighting for our freedom.
That's right.
Fighting for our freedom,
right?
As a podcast warrior,
living my truth.
I think I'm slowly going insane.
Um,
anyways,
I don't have any advertising here.
I don't know what's going.
So fucking podcast has been going off the rails lately.
I'm not gonna lie to you and you don't want to think.
A lot of the biggest fucking problem is,
you know what the biggest fucking problem is right now,
aside from the fact that I have no guests and that sitting here by myself,
you're listening to one of one of,
I'm like a conc cunt right now.
Right.
Um,
the biggest fucking problem I life right now is I'm sober.
You know,
I don't know how the puck and people do this shit.
I'm trying to think back to my life before ever drank
because I had a hell of a run.
I went,
I didn't start drinking until I was like 17,
you know,
I had a couple sips of beer here or there,
but basically I spent the first 16 years of my life sober.
I don't know how I did it,
but I think back,
I didn't have any,
there was no pressure.
You had to get up and do my paper route.
That was the biggest thing.
Occasionally you had to go collecting,
maybe it rained out,
some of the papers got wet.
Maybe there was that.
Maybe he had a book report.
I mean those were the pressure days.
I wonder if kids over in Europe,
you know,
when they got a big book report the next fucking day,
after they give the book report,
do they drink like a fucking couple of shots just to unwind?
You know,
cause there's just so much more progressive over there and they can allow their
kids to booze.
I don't fucking know.
I don't know how it works.
I don't pretend to know.
Um,
but anyways,
I'm committed to this shit though.
I'm not drinking this year.
Okay?
Now I know those animals in Aa,
they tried to say you gotta go day to day.
All right?
But there are different,
they're a different group of people.
All right?
If you ever think you're an alcoholic,
go to an AA meeting and just listen to the fucking stories and you know,
come out the other side and tell me your as fucked up as those people.
I,
I double dare you to fucking do it.
You know,
you're just come out of there and be like,
oh,
you know,
I'm a fucking binge drinker.
That's what I am.
You know what I mean?
Once I start losing teeth,
you know what,
I kind of dial it back.
I'm not standing outside the fucking liquor store waiting for it to open.
Fucking chug and mouthwash.
You ever go to an AA meeting?
You want to feel good about yourself?
You go to a fuck at AA meeting.
Just look at those fucking animals just sitting there.
Goddamn cigarette ashes.
Fucking all over the e the yellow fingers just shoving donuts down there.
Fucking pie halls.
It's unbelievable.
That's funny.
I haven't been on a,
I went to two AA meetings.
Was it one?
Yeah,
to like 30 years ago
only cause the court told me I had to.
Um,
it's a whole other fucking story.
Eli's got until the Stag stag get out guy or a tag.
But I gave it a fucking license back.
All right.
I'll go to these things and that was every fucking story.
They would say the most fucked up shit ever jaw on the ground.
Like you gotta be fucking kidding me.
How did you live through that?
And then right after that,
and they'd be like,
and then the craziest thing is,
you know how they want to do is have another drink.
Jesus Christ.
I love making fun of alcoholics.
I really do.
Alcoholics,
feminists.
Who else?
The Obamas.
I was fucking people.
Jesus Christ.
I don't know what fucking deal with the devil that they signed that they just
fucking get off Scott fucking free out there with all that corporate money
hanging out of their fucking pockets.
Everybody out here is looking at him like they're fucking,
I don't know what.
MMM.
Anyways,
I,
why do I talk politics?
I don't pay attention to it.
Every time I start to look at it,
it just fucking,
I don't know,
it either bores me to tears or scares the shit out of me.
You know?
It's either like somebody filibustering
on the fucking floor or it's like,
I dunno,
you just watch them,
you know,
building up a new candidate.
And so much of it has nothing to do with their message.
It has to do with the way,
the way they look.
Uh,
you know,
it goes back to Clinton,
he played the saxophone on fucking our scenario,
this watershed fucking moments in politics that changes it forever.
You know,
like,
uh,
as far as the age of television,
you had Nixon sweating sitting there like a fucking catcher.
You know what John F.
Kennedy was all tanned up with this fucking legs crossed.
You know,
like he was hanging out at a fucking country club and people who listened to the
debates said Nixon won.
And people who watched it said,
Kennedy won.
You know,
Nixon with his sweaty upper lip.
MMM.
Yeah.
That was it.
That was a moment.
Michael Dukakis sticking his head out of that fucking tank.
Bill Clinton playing the saxophone.
And then I would say,
uh,
Donald Trump,
this last one where he didn't really debate as much as he just sort of trash she
just sorted was doing a roast.
MMM.
That's what I want to see just as a standup comic is how are People gonna
fucking debate.
That guy,
you know,
takes me back to like,
when Patrice was alive,
we just couldn't beat the guy.
So you'd literally walked down to the comedy cellar and I would have like
fucking four insults.
I would just be thinking about his face was something I saw them do on stage and
I would have like four fucking insults ready to go,
you know,
just so I could get to the table and sit down and order some fucking food.
I feel like Trump,
you got to do the same thing.
Like
Hillary should've just abandoned,
you know,
whatever fucking horse shit she was going to say.
Right.
And just fucking attack this to pay,
you know,
and just this stupid look on his face and should've just sat there and imitate
it.
She should just fucking,
uh,
I believe that the,
the,
the youngsters call it clowned him.
He should,
he should've just trashed him back.
Um,
I dunno,
that was such a fascinating fucking thing to see happen.
There was all these fucking rules and he just came in there like a Goddamn bull
in a China shop and traipsed right through all of it.
And those people all had no answer.
All those years I watched those debates in these fucking guys running the
debates,
acting like they had this fucking control that if you fucking broke these rules,
that something was going to happen,
that there was some sort of repercussion for it.
So no one ever did for the most part.
You know,
they talk a little bit over their time.
Trump completely fucking ignored all of them.
And when he did,
they had nothing.
Absolutely fucking nothing.
So I dunno,
what is he like?
He said,
only two years in a little over two years.
So you've got this year,
you got next year and then the show starts again.
What do you guys think?
Let's fucking handicap this
like a football.
It's the beginning of the season.
Who Do you think's gonna win the super like how I wanna know how will you guys,
even if you were into Donald Trump,
cause the guy,
he's a fascinating fucking problem in a debate
cause it's like this guy is just like,
his style is so fucking not what there you all of these fucking politicians,
unless they hosted a reality show,
maybe that's his strength.
He didn't take debating classes so he doesn't know that he just fucking goes in,
you know?
I don't know.
I found it as a standup comedian.
Fascinating.
Mikey was this heckler that you just couldn't get.
I can't shut them.
I just,
when I looked at all those other candidates,
they were like these comedians and they were facing this heckler
that was just funnier than,
than the comic on stage or just wouldn't shut up and there was no security.
They couldn't shut them the fuck up.
The only other time I saw something like that,
I saw bill O'Reilly when he went on the view and he just said whatever the fuck
he wanted and he made them so mad.
Two of them got up and left and he was literally two fucking
hosts away from the hosting the I O'Reilly factor on the fucking view,
you know.
But Babs was fucking old school
and she called the ladies back in.
She's like,
what are we doing?
I sit the fuck back down.
You know,
it's just a man in a shirt saying things relax.
Okay.
And they all fucking relaxed and then that was it.
Um,
anyways,
I love when they walked out too.
Like that meant something like I'm getting up and walking out like all of show
business was gonna was gonna stop,
you know?
I don't know.
Yeah.
I don't know what the fuck's been going on with me lately,
but this is maybe my thought,
like if I've learned anything in my 50 years on this planet is nobody gives a
shit.
Occasionally when somebody gives a shit,
they,
it's,
it's so fucking rare that they actually will do like a piece about it on the
news.
Like we found somebody that gives a shit.
We found somebody who is doing the right thing.
This is what they do and they're doing it the right way.
Why is my voice cracking?
You know,
when they make a documentary about somebody,
there's so few people doing
good things.
I feel that they actually,
that's why they created the documentary.
So it came about,
it's like,
why don't we just make a movie about this person?
Well,
now that there's such a good person,
like it's not going to come off as a believable movie.
You literally have to fucking film this guy or this woman doing this nice shit.
So anybody believes it.
Right.
Am I dreaming this podcast right now?
Is this podcast actually happening?
I have no idea.
I watched a little bit of the Bruins and a little bit of the Celtics.
I've decided that,
uh,
at some point
I do have to put my foot down a little bit and take a little bit of control of
the TV.
You know,
my daughter's just so adorable.
It's hard for me to,
uh,
you know,
say no,
but I,
I know I have to write.
So,
you know,
last night the Bruins were playing the Black Hawks.
So it's just like,
I just want to watch one period of hockey,
I'll watch third period of hockey,
you know,
so I got to put the TV on and I really try not to,
do the screen time thing with my kid.
Uh,
I,
I believe in that whole thing that have in them,
especially with smart phones and all that Shit.
It's just,
it's fucking,
I don't think it's good for him initially.
Um,
and I'm basing that on shit.
I've overheard other people say,
um,
not to mention last weekend when the TV wasn't on and I didn't have my phone and
I just took out a deck of cards and I just had a great fucking time and I was
like,
Oh yeah,
I remember that.
Looking at another person and connected with them.
MMM.
Anyways,
I,
uh,
the fuck is my point here.
Oh yes.
I go to put on the hockey game and the second the TV goes on,
she starts yelling out her shows,
you know,
Mimi Mouse Minnie,
right?
I'm like,
no,
no.
Many miles.
She went to bed many miles,
went to bed,
then she does this crying.
Yeah.
You know,
just forcing it out.
And I'm like,
we're going to watch hockey.
That'd be,
thinks she sees now that sports,
she goes,
football,
my daughter hockey,
hockey.
So Chico was upset for a little bit,
but then,
then she was cool.
And then,
uh,
tonight I put on the Celtics and then she pointed the TV.
She's like,
hockey,
hockey.
I'm like,
no basketball.
So then she,
you know,
said basketball,
we watched that a little bit,
but then she wanted to do the alphabet.
So I put it on mute and I was doing the alphabet with her and then she was kind
of looking at the TV.
So I said,
fuck it.
And I shut it off and just did the whole,
you know,
a apple B bad.
See Cupcake d dinosaur,
rob,
I forget what he is,
you know,
and I go through the whole fucking thing.
Um,
anyways,
um,
so now I'm sitting here,
it's Wednesday night.
I'm doing this fucking podcast cause tomorrow is Valentine's Day and uh,
I have to somehow stay awake.
It fucking go out and go do my spot tonight.
Run my God damn hour.
All I gotta do is just get behind the wheel of the car and that'll wake me up.
I'll stick my head out the window like fucking ace Ventura pet detective
that run down to this little fucking hole in the wall.
I'm gonna run my fucking set and then that'll be it.
I'll be good.
But with,
the thing is,
is I've been getting up,
I've been going to the fucking gym again in the morning.
All right.
And I slowly,
I'm to the point where my shoulder is strong enough where I'm almost to the
point I can do a dip after this rotator cuff fucking nightmare is finally
eyesight.
I,
I did,
I did it so fucking wrong.
I kept babying my shoulder still.
I had that frozen shoulder shit.
Right now I've had to go all the way back and I just keep having setbacks.
But when I finally learned is when I go on the road and I can't go to the gym
when I come back,
I can't pick up where I left it left off.
And I can't even just go five pounds down.
I have to go 15 pounds down or this thing flares up again.
So I finally figured that out.
So now I'm to the point where I take the,
the,
the dip bar,
he can adjust it all the way down.
So on,
basically my feet are on the floor and I'm just sort of bending my legs doing
the dipping motion.
So now I've got it to the point where I'm just sort of,
you know,
when Michael Jackson would come up on his toes,
I'm kind of like that.
So I'm supporting most of the weight of my legs,
but more and more the upper body is going to support it.
And I gotta tell you the day I fucking do a dip,
then I on,
I know I'm getting close and I've been doing,
I disguise,
sent me an about some shoulder exercises and I've been doing this thing where I
just sort of hang from the chin up bar,
you know,
with my feet on the ground.
But every day I do a little more of the upper body holding the weight,
you know,
incrementally every so fucking slowly.
And then I think eventually,
um,
the person I'm working with is telling me because of my body weight,
I need to basically be able to do the lat pull down machine,
like 120 pounds,
three reps of 15.
And when I do that,
then I can attempt to do a pull up without
okay.
Fucking up my rotator cuff and starting all over again and spend a long,
slow fucking road
for an old bastard like myself.
Um,
but anyways,
I'm very excited about slash apprehensive about doing this.
Uh,
this special coming up.
I just,
I fucking,
this is the part that I hate is having to be disciplined because like tonight I
would just go down,
I've just fucking go off and I have to go down and actually work and I'm a lazy
fucker,
so I don't,
I don't like working at being a big goddamn baby about it,
but I'm going to go down,
I'm going to fucking get it done.
And then next week everybody,
uh,
is the Patrice O'neil comedy benefits.
So I'm going to be in New York City doing that benefit.
The next night.
Wednesday I'm actually going to be doing nine o'clock show at Caroline's on
Broadway.
I've not headline there and probably a decade.
And that is the,
the first place that headline to me in New York City,
they used to have to pull the curtain and I would draw like 30 or 40 fucking
people,
anybody they could drag off the Times Square.
Um,
and that's when me,
Patrice Norton,
um,
everyone from my graduating class was just starting to like close out a show on
a uh,
okay,
on like a Tuesday night or whatever.
Man,
it's a really cool thing.
So it kind of takes me back to all of all of those times.
So,
um,
uh,
and then I think I'm in New York for the rest of the week,
so I'll be bouncing around doing spots all around the city,
just stay in shap.
And then I go out from New York,
I'm going straight over to Great Britain,
and then I just bang out about five or six shows there.
And then I do,
uh,
I do two nights at Royal Albert Hall on the fourth and the fifth.
And I knocked this fucker out.
And after that,
oh,
all this fucking crazy political talk and all this negative shit that I've been
doing right now,
it's just because I'm under the pressure.
Don't even fucking listen to me.
Okay.
The world is not as bad as I'm fucking say to this.
I just,
you know,
I just got to get on the other side of this fucking thing.
And once I do,
then I'm good.
Finish.
Right.
The rest ofF is for family.
And then the rest of my year is just opened up.
And then it's my favorite,
favorite fucking time.
Right after a special,
you have no fucking act.
I get to go on stage and just fucking bomb.
It's my favorite thing in the fucking world.
And then also be like,
I don't have to put out another special for a couple of years.
This is beautiful.
Oh,
gives a shit.
If I'm doing a fucking Ronald Reagan impression.
Oh,
I did the ice house the other night.
I had a fucking last night,
ran the hour out there.
Whatever the fuck I did.
Um,
had a great time out there.
Yeah.
You know,
worked with Bart,
Nick Fucking Joe to Rosa J K to braid it.
Can't appraise them.
Um,
trying out some new shit.
I always have to trap the new shit.
I can't just like do my fucking act.
I swear to God.
Then I feel like I'm doing my God damn taxes.
Um,
so anyways,
so you know what,
let's look up some fucking yeah.
Headline News,
Zeke,
and quit listening to me talking about me.
I get to start having more guests on this fucking show.
I think I've exhausted everything I can fucking talk about,
about myself here.
All right,
here we go.
Oh,
look at that.
I'm looking at UK openers.
This is,
uh,
Ian so and so.
This is a fucking something,
something,
something.
All right,
Google,
Google news.
All right,
let's see what's going on here.
Oh,
by the way,
you know something,
I just saw the original,
do you know the original intellectual fucking children's book?
Chicken little,
you know that stupid Goddamn,
uh,
the fuck is it that,
that God damn chicken nae acorn falls on his head.
He says,
the sky's falling.
He runs around and gets everybody off,
you know,
got all in a fucking panic regional chicken little story.
And I got to type in Fox.
Okay.
The original chicken little was a story called Henny penny.
All right,
now chicken little,
I don't even know how that fucking story ended,
but it didn't end up with anybody fucking dying button.
Henny penny chicken little has an acorn falls on his fucking head.
And uh,
whatever your Henny penny,
any penny had a fucking blah,
blah,
blah.
And then he runs into ducky Faqih and he said,
oh,
the sky's falling.
And then Ducky fucking in a Henny penny went up to when went to fucking Loosey
Goosey.
And then there the sky's falling.
And then Lucy Goosey fucky Douggie and Henny penny.
That's how they do it,
right?
It's every fucking bird you could possibly goddamn eat,
freaking out that the fucking sky is falling.
And then they run into a,
the Fox like,
hey man,
what do you guys all freaking out about any penny ducky Faqih and uh,
the,
the fucking Loosey Goosey.
I'll go,
I the sky's falling.
Jesus Christ.
And he goes,
Oh,
you know what?
I live in a cave.
Come on over here and we'll fuck it.
Be Safe.
And uh,
then the story just ends with the Fox in his little fucking Fox cubs,
whatever you call them,
with big smiles on their faces,
cause they fucking hate him.
That's how it ended.
That was the original.
And uh,
people were saying that it was too,
um,
you know,
to fucking dark or whatever the fuck it was.
But uh,
you know,
I have a theory about those old original or some of the old stories like,
or Disney shit like Bambi and why the parents die and all that shit.
You know why that is?
Why it was so fucking dark back then.
Cause people fucking died.
People were hungry.
He had to go out and kill an animal.
You didn't just go down to fucking,
you know,
Goddamn Ralph's and get a chicken breasts.
You had to kill that fucking thing.
Watch it,
flap it's wings for the last time.
Take out the end trails,
be covered in blood and all of that shit.
It was a fucking gory mess.
People got tuberculosis,
they got fucking,
uh,
they got a polio.
All kinds of horrible shit happened back then.
They had gross on their goddamn faces.
It was fucking difficult.
So that was probably a cute story,
you know,
cause they knew so much about wildlife back then,
like,
yeah,
you know the fox,
the Fox is fucking smart man.
You know,
I have no idea.
I don't know.
I just found that fascinating that,
you know,
nowadays,
if you do that,
oh my God,
that's gonna fucking,
there'll be a tragedy.
Oh look at those conference.
All stars.
Please have at my size.
They got the,
they brought the old doctor Jay back.
Please have my size.
How does the Internet,
no,
all right.
There it is.
Oh,
there's an ad.
Let me see.
They got my size.
They never have my size.
It's always fucking sold out.
Oh,
this is so why did they wait so long to bring the old fucking doctor
Jay Leather Converse all star back.
It's such a clean look and fucking sneaker.
All right,
all sizes.
What do you got?
They got my size.
Get the fuck Outta here.
All right,
I'll fucking buy it.
I'm going to click on buy.
Here's how it work.
Make a bid.
Make an author.
Hey,
here's how it works.
Fuck you.
Sneakers.
How about that?
Your cons.
The fuck was that all about you want this sneaker?
We have your size.
All right,
I'll buy it.
All right.
Here's how it works.
What do you mean this is how it works.
All right,
let's get back to the fucking
news here or get to the news.
I haven't got the Google maps is using giant virtual arrows to stop people from
getting lost.
Jesus fucking how much worse can they help you with this thing?
Well,
this is my new pet peeve.
You don't,
when you scroll past the fucking video they want you to watch and then it just
goes down with you stalking you.
Um,
anyways,
here we go.
Google maps wants to make it easier for people to find their way to busy urban
spaces and it thinks large cartoon arrows can help.
August is when you're walking down the street related article,
how Alexa knows the difference between a breaking window in a wine glass.
Oh,
Jesus.
Should I just embrace this shit?
Should I just bring this robot bitch into my fucking house now,
Tommy a batch.
Uh,
all right.
On Monday,
Google Max begin maps began letting some users test a new augmented reality
feature and it's mobile app that shows graphics such as highlighted Arrows and
street names floating in midair over a live view from their camera on their
smartphone screens.
It's meant to help them navigate city streets that Jesus Christ could there be a
more boring fucking article.
What kills me is that there's an entire generation of kids that get excited by
this.
Um,
all right.
Deck of cards with my face on it.
Okay.
This is more exciting to me.
All right.
Custom photo cards.
Oh,
he can actually do this shit
and fucking take a picture.
My God damn nuts.
MMM,
of course.
It's a mother hugging her child.
Who the fuck's gonna put that on a deck of cards.
These cards,
these things are dirty.
They're filthy.
People lose money.
All right.
They lose the relationships with these things.
Let's let the luckiest deck of card Jay ever going to design.
Wait a minute.
Let me,
let me let this up here.
Uh,
booze.
Picture,
deck of cards is what kills me is fucking stupid as this is.
This is going to actually hit something,
right?
It's,
someone's going to have already done this.
All right,
here we go.
Images
just here for the booze.
So we've got that on their fucking cards.
I'm like a chocoholic but for booze.
So look at me.
It all comes back to booze.
Just here for the booze.
Let's,
let's let that something else I like to do.
I'd like to just Google search asshole things are
al Ko holics just weak.
Oh my God.
Somebody said,
are they selfish apps?
A fuckin lutely are alcoholics selfish?
Here we go.
Let's,
let's read this trashy
a deeper look at what into why alcoholics are so selfish.
It's a disease man.
Um,
all right.
Many people seem to think that addicts and alcoholics are quite selfish,
especially when they're using,
oh,
did they?
Do they fucking get me here?
That they're not going to say they're selfish?
Chances are if you had a loved one who is in an active,
active addiction,
we've,
we'd like to invite all active addicts to board next,
please.
Then you've experienced the selfishness of an addict firsthand.
Um,
no.
I'm talking about just like even when they're dry.
Okay,
we'll,
we'll all recovering alcoholics become less selfish,
unfortunately.
No.
Oh,
I love this site.
Not all recovering alcoholics will be willing to address their selfishness.
In reality,
there will be some super selfish people,
including narcissists that we'll continue to being self.
Well,
I mean,
they could say that about anybody,
right?
I'm just being a dick.
Are Elko holics
weak?
This is actually fun searches to just search shit that alcoholics are not
powerless.
Human weakness behind alcoholism.
It's not a good one.
Let's,
let's let one last search here and then I gotta wrap this up.
Are Most feminists fam,
I can't even spell it.
Feminist dumb.
It's not feminist to pour bleach on man.
Spread is,
it's just stupid.
Whoa.
Jesus really do that.
Why anti-feminism is illogical,
evil and incredibly unsexy.
Well,
I want to be sexy.
I thought being a feminist meant I couldn't wear lipstick or crave men with
small behinds.
I thought that,
oh my God.
Can you imagine actually clicking on that and why the fuck would I read that?
Uh,
why did,
why,
what team did to her teacher,
what team did when her teachers said not to be a feminist to people just make
these stories up.
The results of this bay surprise.
You all right.
It's not feminist to pour bleach on man.
Spreaders is just stupid.
Yeah.
I had no idea that that bothered women's so much.
Did just sit there.
It's like we got dick and balls.
We have stuff hanging off of us.
You know,
you've got to make some room there.
Um,
so then all tucked away all nice and fucking tidy.
Like your shit.
I'm all right.
Feminism does not deserve to be undermined by idiotic acts that set men against
women.
Oh my God.
God bless this woman.
Now here's a nice rational fucking person you could talk to.
This is my new video manifesto,
dedicated to the problem of man's spreading,
the disgusting act that is being fought with around the world and it is hushed
up in us.
Yeah.
Men demonstrating their alpha manhood in the subway with women and children
around it has nothing to do with that,
which is sitting there.
You built the whole back story like you sitting there looking at my dick and
balls.
I will take up as much space as I want with my private.
Um,
if you quickly show what kind of macho you are,
we will publicly cool you off.
This video manifesto was created in the assistant with friends who share my
position.
I guess this is,
I guess it's a video of a woman pouring bleach on guys.
All right.
Anyways,
did you hear the one about the Russian student who was so fed up with
manspreading that she took to the subways of Saint Petersburg?
To spray diluted bleach on men's crotches.
Hilarious.
Right?
I got to admit,
that's fucking funny.
And this woman says wrong.
Look,
I hate man spreading as much as the next unreasonable feminists.
It's antisocial,
it's rude.
It's displays an arrogant disregard for this people sitting around you.
It's behavior that women just wouldn't get away with.
What are they talking about?
You use the fucking men's room.
The,
the,
the line is too long in the ladies from you use the mat.
You have no respect for our personal space.
These fucking women,
they're out of their fucking minds.
I'm not saying they don't have some legitimate bitches,
but the way they're acting like they're not doing anything wrong.
It's just straight fucking.
Anyway,
so let's,
let's,
let's read a little more
and to be clear,
I don't mean that I'm advocating for men sitting with their legs clamp together,
lady.
I don't give a fuck what you're at,
what you're acting like you're,
you're,
you're
okay.
You,
you're like,
you've got some sort of legal legislation here that just got passed and then I
have to adhere to this anyways.
I don't eat.
I don't either unless I'm wearing a short skirt.
Nor am I insisting that men should cross their legs at all times.
Oh,
thank you.
Thank you for that.
And that existing that the existence of their penis is no barrier to doing this.
Some may say crossing there,
some men say crossing the legs is fine.
Some men say it isn't not having a penis myself,
I don't feel in a position to be the final arbitrator on this pressing matter.
Uh,
this is not a,
this is one of the dumb,
this is just like,
you know,
global warming.
Who gives a fuck up out that
is dictating our foreign policy.
Who gives shit about this?
Men
trying to sit comfortably on the subway.
MMM.
Anyways,
I think that's the end of the pot.
Yes.
This was a very weird podcast,
but you know what it did
got me
two within two hours of one and a half to go and I got a late in that spot
tonight as home saying I'm an old man.
Oh,
Badu,
dope,
dope.
[inaudible] sitting in the fucking rain to do to to me undies me on days they're
nice and soft.
So there is no pain.
Robin,
on your balls from the left and the right,
you're gonna sleep all fucking night cause your balls,
they're soft with fucking me undies.
Unlike those tidy whities heating up your balls.
All right,
I'm going to fucking car right now.
I'm parked.
I'm doing this safely.
Me undies as yourself.
One fucking important question.
Is your underwear making you happy at this very moment?
What a question to ask on Valentine's Day or were you not thinking about your
underwear?
When do you like to be wearing underwear that is so soft that you feel like
you're making love to an actual cloud all day long?
Uh,
Jeez.
You fucking the hemisphere there.
Well,
I've got one word for you.
Me undies.
Not only will you feel like your loins are being hugged by joy itself,
but me undies gives you multiple style options for both men and the fucking way
days choose between classic colors too adventurous,
prince,
prince like significant auditors,
plant babies and shamrocks.
Speaking of Prince,
why not match your bottom half with your better half and get a matching prints
for you and your partner?
And he says a great offer for my listeners for any first time purchasers,
you order me undies,
you get 50 15% one five 15% off and free shipping.
This is a no brainer.
Get 15% off a pair of the most comfortable undies you will ever put on to get
all to get your 15% off your first fucking pair there.
Free Shipping and a hundred percent satisfaction guarantee.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash bird that's m e u n D,
I e
s.com/burr.
Yeah.
Oh look who it is.
Dollar Shave Club.
Dude.
What the fuck's with their hair on your face there?
Dollar Shave Club has everything you need to look,
feel and smell your best and you never have to go to the store again.
That's because they deliver everything you need right to your dealer and they
help.
They keep your fully stocked on what you use so you don't run out.
Here's how it works.
Dollar Shave Club has everything you need to get ready no matter.
You just fucking said this.
How,
how's that?
Okay.
They haven't this new program where they automatically keep your stocked up on
all your products you use.
You determine what you want and when you want it,
and it shows up right at your door from once a month to once every six months,
however you want to do it.
Plus there's a handsome discount.
The more you buy,
the more you save.
And Right now dollar shave club has a bunch of status sets you can try for just
five bucks like their oral care.
After that,
the restock box ships regular sized products at regular,
at a regular price.
Get your status set for just $5 right now@dollarshaveclub.com slash burr that's
dollar shave club.com/burr
oh,
okay.
All my favorites here.
What's your block butcher box?
My favorite,
I can't even say it.
What's your box delivers healthy 100% grass fed and grass finished beef free
range.
Organic chicken and heritage breed pork,
not bread.
Heritage breed pork.
So tasty.
The incredible quality of butcher box meets starts with the commitment to
raising animals humanely and free of antibiotics and hormones.
Listening to the feminist manifesto before they're slaughtered.
Cook with p the peace of mind knowing you are eating healthy,
high quality meat.
Each box comes at least two with at least eight,
eight,
two 11 pounds of meat,
which is enough for 24 individual size meals.
You Fat Fox,
she get 24 meals out of that,
you can choose from five different box types.
All beef,
beef and chicken,
beef and pork mixed box.
We ain't about that around here.
You stay with your own,
uh,
custom box lets you choose your own cuts.
My favorite cut of meat is the heritage breed pork.
Oh,
you do that?
A little bit of mashed potatoes,
right?
Little bit of fucking all natural Gornick or,
or going organic fucking apple sauce.
Sear it on both sides.
Finish it in the oven.
Take it out with a little rosemary garlic Beth butter bath.
Oh Jesus.
But two picks,
a two free Philemon,
Y'alls Free Bacon and $20 off your order of Jesus Christ.
Go to butcher box.com/burr and enter Burra chick checkout.
Go.
Now this is over a $50 value and available for a limited time.
This makes me want to sign up for it again
to free Philemon,
yawns and Free Bacon.
This is a company that understands America,
butcher box.com/burr and enter burr at checkout.
Okay.
Thank you for listening to this absolute fucking bullshit
of a podcast.
Um,
I'm actually having,
um,
oh,
I have a,
I have a big guests coming on for the Monday morning podcast.
Uh,
I got Jason Reitman who I was lucky enough to work with on the front runner and
um,
that movie is coming on to all the streaming services.
I believe maybe today it came on or,
or sometimes soon.
So Jason was nice enough to agree.
I asked them to come on the podcast so we could come on and promote that movie.
Um,
it's one of my favorite things that I've done.
So we're going to talk that we're going to talk movies,
he's going to be,
I think directing the next ghostbuster movie and all that type of stuff.
So that's
what I'm going to have for you on Monday.
And um,
other than that,
we've got a little bit of music here and after that we'll have another half hour
of a throwback Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast.
God bless all of you,
especially all the strong brave women who listen to this.
Um,
without you,
the world would be nothing.
Okay.
And I'm closing my leg
as I fucking hit stop on my recorder.
[inaudible]
last week,
you know,
I was bitching about Valentine's Day.
You know,
I always tease you about,
you know,
how we go out to celebrate our relationship except iPad by the way.
How,
how,
how much fun was it going out on the 12th?
It was really nice.
It was great doing that from now on.
Right?
It was still going to be our nice,
quiet,
romantic.
Yep.
There was none of the hype.
We went to a really nice place.
I'm not gonna lie,
it wasn't actually cheap,
but I,
I can't imagine what that would've caused.
We would've been standing outside.
Oh yeah.
You know,
you and your little glitter dress looking at the other girls in there.
Glitter dress is going to you like Mike Literature.
I as much as her,
I should've gotten mine in poofy shoe shoe colors.
Um,
so anyways,
so I've been bitching about the ladies on this thing,
right?
Like what do you guys do?
And they're talking about this steak and a blow job day.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
All right.
I like it.
I'll tell you when you were in heaven,
when not only can they not,
I can't say it.
Yeah.
When,
when they're,
when they're proficient in both of those categories,
because there's a lot of people out there,
they're going to say,
all right,
steak,
get a blow job day.
And one of them is it going to be up to snuff.
And there is,
there is a prevailing attitude amongst women that they are just automatically
good in bed because they're there and there's the prevailing attitude that men
don't know what's going on.
We don't know what's going w where anything is,
we're just happy to be at.
It's a privilege,
which is why this lady says the Valentine's Day,
this is,
this is from a lady.
She said,
hey bill,
I heard what you were saying about women and Valentine's Day and how we don't
buy our men gifts and we expect a whole day to be about us.
Well,
here's what I did from my husband.
Uh,
by the way,
I'm honestly not trying to sell you anything.
He goes,
she goes,
I bought him the liberator Wedge Ramp Combo set.
Uh,
what's that?
You might ask actually know about this from the European Anthony Show.
They refer to it as a bedroom,
as bedroom,
adventure gear.
It's a set of cushions designed to help you achieve more positions during sex as
well as deeper penetration.
So no,
we didn't go out to dinner.
No stupid cards were exchanged.
We simply stayed home and fucked all night.
Choke on that.
You douchebag.
I love your bill.
Go Fuck Yourself.
I like this girl.
Yeah,
but you know what's funny about that?
As she's patting herself on the back,
she bought something for herself.
It's for both of them.
No,
it isn't.
What do you mean it is she going to do with it without him?
I don't need deeper penetration.
That's feel wealthy.
Again,
that's,
that's the difference.
What is the difference?
She knows.
I'm not saying that guys don't satisfy their women properly,
that they,
that their dick isn't big enough.
I'm not talking about that.
I'm talking about how she's patting herself on the back.
Like she went out and bought this guy,
the NFL package for next season.
Like she actually went out and bought something for him.
She didn't at the very least she bought something for them.
But the real thing about that,
that's for the woman so he can hit it at that angle that you liked so he can hit
your spot so we can get in there deeper.
Guys don't appreciate that.
I'm not saying I don't appreciate it and I'm not saying it's not a great
invention,
but what I'm saying is she's acting as though like this was some sort of a
sacrifice that she basically bought him something that would get her better Dick
and she's patting herself on the back for it.
It's fucking ridiculous.
I think it's clever.
It is clever because she's acting as though she did something but she didn't
see this is the,
this is the thing about that is the genius of women is you guys act like sex
doesn't feel good for you too.
You Act like you guys allowing us to have sex with you.
Like you don't want it and like this,
it's like you like waxing a floor and it's just a big fucking pain in the ass.
You know?
She got some in that in that is like celebrate Tory of their relationship as
opposed to like the typical dinner.
It's like it's about our intimacy.
It's about our connection.
So why don't we get something that will enhance that?
Yeah,
but this is the thing.
I got to go out and buy you like some necklace or some let me go.
How do I get to wear it?
I got to take you out to dinner,
celebrate and I pay for the whole fucking thing.
It's all about the guy going out,
spending money on you,
getting you shit that you want.
And it's the pressures for the guy to show his love to you.
Oh,
I know a white guy who can dunk a basketball.
All right,
let's stop talking about the exceptions.
I'm talking about the fucking rule here.
All right.
Okay.
You know what I'm saying?
Yes,
I do.
Okay.
All right.
All right,
fine.
There we go.
Via tapping out.
Fucking tapping out.
Why?
Why Do Women Act Lik sex doesn't feel good to them?
Why do you,
why do you,
what do you guys know?
I can't answer it.
Can you please talk into the mic?
I'm not like that,
so I don't know.
I couldn't tell you.
You don't have any insight.
I can't keep this going.
All right,
let's keep going.
I don't really know.
Women that are like,
Oh God,
it's such a chore.
Like maybe in next 10 years women will be complaining about that.
I don't know,
but,
well,
when I was making fun of Valentine's Day this weekend,
some girl in the crowd was going like,
you know what?
I said,
well,
what did you do for it?
And she goes,
she,
he got to hit this and
god,
it's ridiculous.
Yeah.
What can I just show up and be like,
hey,
you get to suck this lady never,
never.
Ain't never got to do that.
Right.
I don't know what it is complaining about.
This is what it is.
If guys could ever stop being such fucking sluts and giving it a well,
that's why women women don't respect Dick is because it's so easy for them to
get it.
If you'd stop giving it away,
if,
if every guy would just start the day and fucking rub one out,
right world would be a lot more peaceful at least until two in the afternoon.
By then your balls fill up again.
Start getting competitive by his cubicle bigger than mine.
Um,
I don't even know what I'm saying here.
It's just,
it's,
you know what it is.
It's just one of those things that balances it out.
Right?
I can choke slam you on the floor and you could cut off the sex and that
balances out,
but it's illegal for me to hit you.
But for some reason it's not illegal for you to cut off the sex and that right
there people is what's known as the tipping point.
That's how you lose.
Yep.
[inaudible]
Hey,
what's going on?
It is Belper and it is the Monday morning part
cash for Monday,
February 14th,
2011 happy Valentine's Day.
You bunch of fags.
The fuck is wrong with you,
Huh?
All you douchebags out there buying flowers and fucking candy at cvs that is in
love.
Huh?
You bunch of fucking shape.
What are you doing
the fuck?
What's wrong with you?
Somebody ought to know where it tells you this is the day you got to go tell
that fucking pain in the ass that you love her.
What she doing for you?
Is She paying for dinner tonight?
Did she have to go make reservations?
What the fuck is she going to do other than get ready?
I got news for you.
She's not doing a fucking thing.
All right,
so why don't you save yourself some money?
Pick a fight with their today.
All right,
anything she says,
so you'd just be like,
that's what this is what I'm talking about.
And then just storm out,
you know,
and just let her leave 40 messages.
You're not picking up and it's scaring me.
Okay,
let's,
let's work it out and just wait till tomorrow.
Just wait till tomorrow.
There's plenty of reservations that fucking candy 75% off.
Come on people.
Come on fellas.
You better than this.
You're better than this.
Don't get,
don't get sucked into this stupid ass fucking holiday.
I know what you're thinking.
Well,
what are you going to do?
Work to fuck?
I'll tell you what the fuck I'm doing.
I sat down at a nice mature conversation with my Horman and I said,
listen,
this is fucking stupid.
All right,
this d,
every restaurant's going to be packed.
You know?
Would you care for the heavily Shugar for $900 he went out of my,
can I just grab your fucking weight or face and just shove it in something,
right.
Add to whatever.
You know what I'm saying?
I actually worked out with my girl this year.
I said,
listen,
I'll take you out on the 15th.
All right,
I'll take you to a nice fine restaurant where there'll be plenty of goddamn
tables.
You know,
there won't be some sad fucking,
uh,
immigrant with flowers coming by with an accordion every five seconds,
you know,
she's taking the night off.
We can sit there and actually enjoy the Goddamn meal for raw,
you know,
only 30% markup as opposed to 200%.
What I'm trying to say people is,
uh,
if you want to find out if you're with someone who's cool,
they're just see if they'll celebrate Valentine's Day on like the 16th or the
15th.
You know,
it's like Vegas go there right after the new years,
when new year when everybody's fucking broke.
That's when you go,
you get a hotel room for like seven bucks.
Oh yeah.
I'm telling you,
go on fucking orbits.
You think I'm lying to you?
Um,
whatever.
Wa what w what do you,
what are you going,
I just,
I hate this holiday.
All right.
I'm not a fan of love.
So this holiday annoys the shit out of me.
And you know,
fans of my podcast should realize,
do I flip out like this on flag day?
I don't,
I don't care if you have a flag.
I don't know.
I don't have a problem with it.
You know why?
Cause there's no fucking social pressure for me to go out and get one.
What kind of flag did he get you?
Oh,
he only got you that one.
Do you know what that one means?
Why don't you fucking shove it up your Twat and dry it out?
Why don't you do that?
Oh,
cheese is bill Jesus.
You're going to get that dirty,
this eat early.
Yes,
I am.
Listen people,
I have some new information for you.
Um,
that has,
that pertains to,
that pertains to the podcast.
Um,
I have a new email address from here on out.
If you want your shit answered or red on my podcast,
this is the email that you have to send it to
bill@themmpodcast.com all once again,
Bill B as in bill,
I as an ill l l bill@themmpodcast.com.
That's where you send it.
And if you could help me out in the,
in the,
in the subject line just right,
you know,
like,
is it racist advice?
Overrated.
Underrated.
Just helped me out a little bit.
Could you guys,
could you do that for me?
For the love of God.
Could you lift your fucking fingers,
put it on the Goddamn keyboard and helped me up just a little bit.
You know,
look at you.
Look at you with your large iced coffee.
Just sitting there waiting for the world to fucking help you out.
Isn't it time?
You fucking hell.
Let me out.
Please send all emails to
bill@themlmpodcast.com.
Put the goddamn subject in,
in,
in the title,
uh,
the sub and the subject line.
Put the title.
That's what the fuck.
I'm trying to sit here and a the,
and by the way,
I keep saying the official website of the Monday morning podcast and I think I
always forget to say the,
it's www.themmpodcast.com if you'd like to follow along in your cubicle at work
on a plane,
whatever the fuck you want to do.
So I'm,
I'm actually doing this Sunday night,
once again,
I'm going to put it up nice and early.
So,
uh,
all my,
my 17 fans in Great Britain and my two fans in the Scandinavian area,
we'll actually get it on Monday morning so I don't have to listen to people
fucking bitching at me.
Um,
I just went to a,
I went to a Grammy's party.
Can you believe that?
Happy me.
Went to a Grammy's party.
I lasted an hour and 20 minutes and um,
I watched the first little number there,
um,
where they had the,
the,
the five whaling whores,
you know,
just
reaching like a bunch of God damn alley cats.
Like how did,
how did that become singing?
It's like they,
they are amazing singers.
All right.
The,
uh,
the black chick.
It used to be the fat chick is now the skinny chick.
She's out there.
Waylon shaken her fucking,
we've around Christina Aguilera with their fucking booze face,
right?
And her little fucking special Horry Mike stand.
She's wailing away.
Then they had was that,
that Kathy Griffin,
look and check all of them.
The old Whitney Houston look broad.
They dragged out all just hitting every note that they could possibly hit every
12 fucking seconds.
They sounded like a bunch of fucking alley cats.
Whoa.
Yeah.
Shut up.
Alia.
The fuck is wrong with you.
Sing the Goddamn Song.
You know,
you fucking hold on to it and then you surprise people.
Then you wan Lee Shit.
Just get up there fucking screaming like someone standing on your foot that's
not fucking singing
all five of them.
Somebody just needed to sit them down.
Oh.
And then they're dead.
Fucking amazing.
Created one comes out,
uh,
Lady Gaga.
Right?
You know what?
I can't stand.
I hate paint by numbers.
Shock.
I can't fucking stand it.
And uh,
but it's,
it's a,
it's a very smart career choice.
She works.
She was on the red carpet and she fucking was in,
uh,
what the fuck was she in?
What is a proper medical?
An ovary.
What the fuck was,
she was in a womb,
her warm is sopa loaded.
She was in a fucking wome,
right?
I mean,
that is like fucking page one of stupid ass,
like a stupid college student film from like 1963.
That was like shocking when Jim Morrison first started shaving.
All right.
Jesus Christ,
you show up in the fucking thing.
More cues to be in that supposed to be artistic and everybody's supposed to be,
you know,
and I'm a tell you fucking right now she's going to be around for 40 fucking
years because people who do that shit,
it's,
I dunno,
I dunno
what's,
what's she going to do next year?
You,
she gonna show up next year and like an old shoe and then come out dressed in
like a socket miniskirt you know,
commenting on the shoeless people in the fucking world.
And then she goes out and she sings basically a Madonna Song.
I was at the party and everyone was singing Madonna song over it and it and it,
and it meshed perfectly with it.
Express yourself.
Sounded like what she was singing and then she had all these fucking people
dancing around her,
right?
And then they have like that expressionless like a post apocalyptic makeup on,
you know,
that they owe hs was fucking horrific.
And at that point,
you know,
at this point I'm in the kitchen and I'm eating a fucking slice of cheesecake
just for what,
what am I eating it for?
You know,
why am I eat?
I'm just doing that so I can avoid that other shit.
It was horrific.
And I had a real brutal day.
I got a flat tire on my Prius.
Uh,
fuck.
It was just,
you know,
if one of those deals where,
uh,
the,
the front left tire was low,
all right.
And I see that it's low.
So I go to a gas station,
I go,
I'm like,
well that's odd.
So I put air in the tire.
This,
this whole fucking thing was my fault,
right?
So I put air in the tire and then I just kind of keep an eye on it.
It's went down a little bit,
but not as much as it had in back of my head.
My brain's going like,
dude,
what are you,
what are you fucking idiot?
Take it,
take it over to somebody and check.
You probably got a slow leak.
Maybe they can patch it up,
blah blah blah blah blah.
And I fucking blow it off.
Start driving 70 miles an hour.
Just completely ignoring the fucking thing.
You know in the back of my head the entire time I've owned the car I'm like,
you know bill,
you know,
okay you know this thing has one of those pieces of Shit Jacks that you have to
assemble and then it has that little hand crank.
Like I'm trying to start like a fucking model t in the early 19 hundreds right.
I knew that and I knew it was going to have some half ass fucking that l shape
lug nut thing that you can get like half a pound of torque on and there's no way
to get the lug nuts off.
Cause they fucking put a mom a dad thing and they don't,
they,
they don't stop after it's tight and they go
like,
they fucking,
there's no way to get that thing you need.
I knew what I needed.
I needed a,
you need a big piece of pipe that you fit over that piece of shit,
right angle fucking lug nut thing and then you can,
you can take them off and I didn't have it.
So whatever.
So I went to go do for,
uh,
I went to go do the long shot podcasts,
right?
I was doing that fucking thing and I'm driving out
and um,
I just hear this noise and my car wasn't moving smoothly and I was like that,
do I have the emergency brake on?
What the fuck's going on?
Then I go,
Oh God,
oh Geesh.
And I pull over and there I am riding on the fucking rim.
So I'm like,
Nah,
I,
and I drive a Prius so I'm already on for spare tires to begin with.
Okay.
God knows what the fucking temporary spares gonna look like.
Um,
turns out,
it looks like,
you know,
when you used,
when you suck on a fucking
lifesaver,
a lifesaver,
you know,
you know when you get to that point,
right.
We have just tried to keep sucking on it without breaking it and you get to that
point right before it breaks.
That's,
that's what my temporary spare looks like.
And the rim is painted bright yellow.
Yeah.
Uh,
I have a picture of it,
which will be up on the m M podcast.com.
Um,
so anyways,
anyways,
uh,
I pull into a gas station,
which back in the day 12 guys would attack my car and what have the fucking
thing change before I even stopped.
But now you show up,
there's no garage at a gas station anymore because that entire area is to sell
fucking Ho hos and snowballs.
Um,
and gum.
So I walk in,
I say,
yeah,
listen,
I got a flat,
can you,
can you call a tow truck?
He goes,
well,
yeah,
I mean,
you know,
I can basically do what you do.
I just call information.
Sounds like I get it.
I understand this wasn't your dream in life,
was it?
Okay,
I'll go fuck myself.
So I go back out to the hotel,
a hotel.
I go out to the fucking,
uh,
the God damn parking lot,
right?
And immediately,
you know,
homeless people start approaching me like,
like,
I mean a Zombie movie,
you know?
Yeah.
You don't notice if you just go to get gas at a gas station,
you don't realize all the Weirdos.
But when you're fucking sitting there and you
have a flat and there's nowhere to go,
they just didn't come out of fucking nowhere.
And I'm like,
why are there all these fucking homeless people at a God damn gas station?
I don't fucking understand.
They don't have cars
if fucking homeless.
Right.
Why are they are,
are they at the gas station?
And it turns out,
I finally figured it out,
especially in La,
which is everybody drives,
there's no one to panhandle to.
You need to get them when they're getting out of their fucking cars.
So they hang at the God damn gas stations.
These people keep showing up,
you know,
hey man,
can you give me a dollar?
No,
I can't go fuck yourself.
All right,
because you'll look like a drunk,
sir.
You don't look like a guy who lost his job and he's down on his luck.
You look like a fucking drunk.
All right.
Fucking loser.
Get out of here.
Get a job.
You're a bum.
You understand me?
You're not homeless.
You're a fucking bum.
That was my attitude.
And anyways,
so uh,
call up,
you know,
I call up the tow truck
[inaudible] 10 minutes by Fred [inaudible].
That shit,
you know,
then you call them back.
20 off,
20 minutes later,
my friend Fred to 20 minutes per tap app.
App App,
right.
Fucking debt goes on.
10 minutes was like an hour and a half and I was a little,
not already 15 minutes and I was just sitting there going like,
what did I call it?
Like three at like four 10 past four.
I was like,
if this fucking Douche doesn't get here by four 15,
all right,
I'm calling a friend,
I'm going over to a hardware store and I'm buying a piece of fucking pipe and
I'm going to,
I'm going to figure out my jack and I'm going to do this myself.
Unfortunately,
this fucking guy finally shows up with his giant Goddamn truck,
which he leaves running,
which is fantastic,
right?
So we can just sit there breathing in the fumes and uh,
you know,
whatever.
He fucking changed the tide,
the goddamn tire.
And,
uh,
this temporary spare is so God damn small.
Um,
I just drove home with it and I parked the car and I'm like,
that's it.
I'm done.
I'm dry.
I'm driving this car home and then I'm driving it over to the dealership
tomorrow.
That is it.
That is how small his fucking tire is.
Like the,
what the fuck light was on,
on my dashboard with a temporary spare.
So,
uh,
I don't know.
That's my fucking,
that was my God damn day.
That's what happened to me today.
People
don't really take me 15 minutes to tell.
You got to fucking flat on my car.
Are you really still listening to this or you may get upset with me.
Um,
somebody sent me this article,
actually the,
the,
uh,
the person who runs the MM podcast.com,
the official podcast page of the Monday morning podcast,
uh,
sent me this,
this article here.
Um,
it's called the day of the lout l o u t from the Los Angeles Times and it's
written,
um,
bias actually by some guy,
believe it or not.
And it says unsophisticated,
lazy,
misogynistic males may be the primary model for today's young American men.
Uh,
and I'm sitting there going,
where the fuck is this guy seeing this?
Because all I see is a bunch of pussy whipped fags,
you know?
Okay.
All right.
Since the way he says,
if you've seen a beer commercial the last two years and how can you avoid them?
Well,
you could read,
you could Tivo shows.
See Right off the bat,
this guy's a Douche.
She's trashing men and now he has problems with beer commercials.
How could you avoid them?
I mean room.
Um,
he says,
you know,
the type,
he's,
he's a 20 or 30,
something,
sort of a slacker with a beautiful and adoring girlfriend who just can't seem to
prize attention away from his suds.
She expresses ardor.
He looks ardently at his mug or can of beer.
I don't know what art means.
I don't even know if I'm pronouncing that correctly.
She wants to talk romance.
He wants to talk anything.
But she gets exasperated.
He snuggles obviously with his beer and she departs in a huff.
Most Martin takes on manhood say that guys will do anything to bed a woman.
But this is a new kind of man and he seems to be everywhere these days,
not just on beer commercials,
but in movies,
on TV on hundreds of morning radio shows and in bestselling books to the point
where he's generating a culture of new masculinity.
He may even be the primary model for young manhood in America today.
All right?
This guy has clearly decided to just completely ignore how much women are
fucking pandered to and how you can make a guy look like an absolute retard in
any commercial.
They always make the,
for the most part,
so many commercials make the guide look like the moron.
You know,
I'm not saying 100%,
but can't they have a couple ones where the guy is a dick?
I'm not saying in every,
in every commercial,
every TV show,
the guy's gotta be cool and he should act like he doesn't give a shit about his
wife.
But I mean,
I dunno if I should legally be saying this,
but,
uh,
there's three things that recently,
how the fuck can I put this?
Okay.
Uh,
show ideas,
pilots that are being made out here in Hollywood.
You want to hear him?
Fuck it.
Who gives a shit?
Okay.
One of them was a,
the idea was for a guy who
the audition was to play a guy who actually speaks his mind.
But the reason why he speaks his mind is because he got hit on the head and had
a fucking aneurism and he almost died.
So then they're thinking,
is this some weird side effect that a man is actually speaking his mind?
I swear to God,
this is a TV show that they're going to put millions of dollars behind and a,
and this is how he speaks his mind in the pilot.
He actually,
uh,
I might get in trouble if I see what the material is.
He makes a comment about how big the girls asses,
you know,
but of course he likes it.
He likes it or asked is big.
So it's self serving to women.
Yeah.
You know?
It's basically say,
yeah,
it's great that now that we're married,
you've become a dumpy fat.
Fuck sweetheart.
I'm speaking my mind.
Totally pan or into the broad.
Then there's another show that's in development.
I guess I can talk about this.
It's in fucking development.
It's not a goddamn secret.
This is the,
this is,
I swear to God,
this is the premise of the show.
Uh,
two guys realize that it's a woman's world.
So they decide to dress as women to get jobs at a pharmacy and through dressing
like women,
they become better men.
I swear to God.
Yeah.
All right.
And this is,
I got all of these auditions in a week.
I said no to all of these.
All right?
Because I would,
I would become a,
I would become an alcoholic.
I don't give up.
I don't need,
I don't need that.
All right.
I'm already a fuck up.
I could,
there's no fucking way.
And then the last one was a guy who is in the shadow of his spouse,
uh,
his,
his famous spouse and gets upset because he's always teased that he's the wife
in the relationship.
And the guy's first name is Gail,
you know,
that's could go either way.
Like gale sayers.
Uh Huh.
Yeah.
So I don't know what the fuck this guy is bitching about.
And there's plenty of those.
There's all those beer commercials where the women are going like,
yeah,
well I'll,
I'll tell you what's a good beer when you take your skirt off,
you half a fucking pussy,
right?
All those ones in the guys wearing the tight jeans and looking like Douche bags
and having sunglasses on.
So this guy just chose to look at this very spot.
This is like a guy,
this Guy Neil.
I bet he got the shit kicked out of him in high school by guys like this.
And what kind of a guy really gets annoyed?
Buy Beer commercials.
Really?
Are they really dumb?
Do they really fucking appeal to the lowest common denominator?
Of course they do.
Your fucking moron.
You want some art?
Go rent a good movie.
Well I think,
oh well is,
is he like,
like reminiscing back in the day when they had good beer commercials,
quality beer commercials,
sweat when they had those fucking lizards talking to each other.
I Dunno
Neal Gabler go fuck yourself.
You got everybody trying to get laid this week?
Is that what you had to write that loud?
Um,
so anyways,
did that go anywhere?
Has his podcast going anywhere to 22 fucking minutes in Jesus.
Yeah.
Oh,
fucking geezers.
Um,
what's actually,
let's,
let's read some things here.
Yeah.
Bill,
that that'll make it better if you actually start to read.
You know,
it was funny,
as I sat there,
I was at that,
that Goddamn a grammy party,
and I was trashing lady Gaga.
Knowing in the back of my head,
it was annoying the shit out of my girlfriend.
She absolutely hates my behavior.
When I go to parties.
She can't stand it.
She thinks I'm antisocial and she thinks when I say things,
I just say douchey things.
MMM.
I don't know what it is.
She,
someone who kind of goes,
all I can say,
she goes along,
I don't know what the fuck it is,
but like,
mmm,
she's not happy with me right now.
She doesn't like that.
I made fun of Lady Gaga who was evidently singing express yourself.
I Dunno.
What the fuck was I supposed to do?
I walked in there.
I just,
I immediately didn't feel comfortable.
I dunno.
All right,
let's plow ahead here.
Um,
how about some advice?
I haven't done one of these in a while when I give something my bed.
Oh,
here's a guy bitching about a two drink minimums at comedy clubs,
says a bilge.
Jimmy Norton is my favorite comic.
Um,
he's getting ready to go on right now at the Melrose improv yet.
Jim Norton played the Improv right here in Melrose,
right here in Los Angeles,
um,
Saturday night.
So his favorite comedian is Jimmy Norton.
And uh,
he says,
I guess he's writing this as the show's Bart raid happened.
He says he's ready to go on right now with the Melrose improv Saturday night.
Guess who's not there?
Not just me,
but probably 50 other assholes that love him and we could,
would kill to see him.
I know it's not Jimmy's fault.
Uh,
it's not any of the performer's fault,
but are any of these cock sucking club owners are aware that the economy,
that the economy is in the fucking toilet right now?
No Sir.
I'm sure they have no idea.
Considering when the economy goes into the toilet,
one of the first things people cut out as entertainment.
Yeah,
I'm sure they're completely immune.
To the economy.
The economy,
sorry,
my voice is cracking.
He said I've skipped most of the handful of live type events I've wanted to see
for the last six months or so because of this exorbitantly priced shit.
How can these clubs justify selling the place,
selling the place out with $25 tickets to see the guy then charge their two
drink minimum with their $8 beers,
$6 bottle waters and $10 mixed strengths.
So when all is said and done,
you've spent like $40 or more to see a comic who can afford that kind of shit.
I don't know sir.
With a paper
route,
you're really complaining that it costs 40 fucking dollars,
sir.
This is how it works.
Do you know you have expenses in life?
Club owners also have expenses.
They have to pay the comedian.
All right?
They have to pay taxes,
they have to pay to get a liquor license,
they have to pay all of that shit and then they have to be
pay their mortgages and all of that type of stuff.
And the reason why they have a two drink minimum is because tight fox would go
there and just order waters and they wouldn't make any money and they would go
out of business.
All right,
now I'm not mocking you because you can't afford $40 I guess I kind of made
funny,
but what the fuck,
sir?
$40 how much does it cost to go to a football game?
Costs 20 bucks to park.
All right
to go down and see the great Jimmy Norton for Florida.
$40 you're gonna fucking complain about that because you got to buy a couple of
$10 Shirley temples.
You know,
you know what your problem is,
Sarah?
I don't think you have your priorities straight.
You don't look around your apartment.
You know what?
Are you guys ready to get a George Foreman Grill?
How much did that cost?
You know,
does it really work?
cooks chicken and fucking eight minutes.
Yeah.
How does that taste?
Was that worth it?
Do you ever see fucking George Foreman's house?
Just got to get so fucking rich.
She named all these kids the same goddamn name.
That's how fucking Richie is.
Like he doesn't need to
give a fuck that,
that he do something like that.
Sorry.
You're way out of line complaining about that.
Okay.
You know what you sound like,
you sound like all these kids today who go on Youtube and they get upset when a
video gets taken down these fuck goddamn copyright crunch.
It's like they,
they don't seem to understand that things cost money.
So you have to charge for them.
And when you put up hundreds of thousands of dollars to produce a film or saw a
music or an album that if people just take it and they put it on fucking
youtube,
you don't get your money back.
You know?
So there you go.
Sir.
Believer it or not a comedy club,
it costs money to run a comedy club.
And not to mention sometimes they give comedians guarantees like no matter if
five people show up a 500 we still have to pay you this amount of money.
And then when five people show up,
they lose their goddamn shirts.
It's not like they're making tons of fucking money every God damn weekend.
There's a lot of shit that goes into it.
And like I said,
you know,
people are tight fucks and if he didn't make them buy drinks,
they would just sit there
booze in the parking lot and then they would just fucking sit there and the club
would go out of business.
So I think 40 to see a
one of the top comp comics in the country,
I think that's pretty God damn reasonable.
And uh,
you know,
I don't want to tell you how much it costs to go to a fucking movie.
At least half that is John Travolta standing.
They alive dancing for you.
He isn't.
I don't know.
Am I being a Dick here?
Where did I lose the funny on this podcast?
Because I already did an hour long podcast for somebody else today.
I think I'm all podcast it out.
All right,
let's get to,
is it racist,
racist?
Um,
this is the new of the new fucking thing here that everybody seems to like.
Uh,
is it racist?
Um,
Bill,
although I thought,
I also thought I'd share a little game that I used to play.
I like this one right here.
This is a great game.
You know,
I played that older Asian game.
Anytime anybody cuts me off in traffic,
uh,
somebody says a turnoff.
I,
this is a game I like to play.
I turn on the TV and without looking,
I try to guess the race of the person talking.
I call it the Tony Gwynn game.
Now for those of you who aren't sports fans,
Tony Gwynn is African American and he sounds like a def jam comic imitating a
White Guy.
If you closed your eyes,
you wouldn't even think that you were listening to a white guy.
You would think you were listening to a black guy imitating a white guy.
He,
he,
he talks like he basically like,
yeah,
I was talking to Ted Williams the other day and he's really big on headache.
Dad.
Uh,
I'm,
I'm not,
I can't even do it.
I'm not even doing it.
Well not even doing it justice.
And I asked him how to hit the other side.
Curve Ball.
Um,
the Tony Gwynn game.
Yeah.
Cause he is the wild card.
Do you guys tickets racist?
Like,
I remember back in the day when the Oj trial,
when,
uh,
someone said they heard some yelling and it's sounded like a black guy and
people tried to say that that was racist and it's like,
that is not fucking racist.
You know what I mean?
If you heard somebody on the other side of a fence going,
ah,
it's,
it's a petty smart,
right.
Would you be like,
oh,
let's,
I think that they're,
that guy could be Italian,
sorry for my Hacky fucking Asian offensive,
uh,
accent there.
But you know what I mean?
Like if you were to listen to me,
not only would you know I was a guest that I was a white guy,
you would guess that I was from the east coast,
wouldn't ya?
Just cause you can guess who the fuck somebody is.
Doesn't mean it's racist.
That's like somebody,
somebody send me an email,
said,
bill,
he goes,
you're older.
Asian game is racist as shit.
I'm sorry that that was the person's entire fucking email.
It's like you would call,
can you,
can you elaborate a little bit so you can enlighten me?
Your game is racist as shit.
Oh,
well,
you know,
thanks for clearing that up.
I don't know what you're apologizing for.
I hate when people say I hate that.
That's like that fucking,
uh,
you know,
I listened to your act.
I didn't like it.
You know,
I'm,
I'm sorry.
I,
but I didn't like why are you apologizing?
I hate like that whole,
like you're assuming that you fucking hurt my feelings.
I don't give a fuck if you take my game is racist or not.
I know it isn't.
I don't have,
I don't have any bad feelings towards old people or Asians.
I'm just addressing the fact that most of the time out here when somebody does
something fucked up,
you know,
is it racist to say white people can't dance because we can't.
There are examples.
John Travolta,
I believe I already brought up that man can dance,
but it's not racist if some,
if somebody black told me said,
you know what?
White people cannot fucking dance.
You guys don't have any fucking rhythm.
I,
when I sit there and that's not racist,
I'm sorry,
but it isn't.
Um,
okay.
You know,
that's something I actually,
that hasn't been brought up in this whole is it,
is it racist,
racist,
um,
topic than I'm doing here is uh,
I think that before you fly off the fucking handle and get offended,
you have to at least,
you know,
not all the time,
but 10% of the time don't you feel that you kind of have to own up to the fact
that
Ah,
how do I put this?
It's like when Arabs got upset after nine 11 when they were,
they were getting searched for no fucking reason other than the fact that they
were Arab.
And that's definitely offensive is definitely fucking annoying and,
and all of that type of shit,
but on some level,
don't you feel you have a responsibility to address the 18 Arabs that fucked it
up for you.
You know,
it's like that white people can't fucking dance.
All right.
Are they can't jump or whatever.
I mean,
okay,
what am I supposed to do?
You know how offended he is,
but at some point you got,
you kinda gotta like here's one for you.
Let me run me,
read this shit here.
Um,
not raise my computer goes out.
Uh,
Bill,
I can't really use names,
but I have a friend who is alignment for a division one football school.
He has a friend who plays in the NFL as a wide receiver.
He,
the wide receivers also white.
Um,
my friend the Lyman told me that the wide receiver told him that he's tried out
for four NFL teams.
Two of the four told him his chances of making the team were not good because he
was white.
I've had a few arguments with people.
Uh,
is it racist?
Should the NFL should at the NFL teams even mentioned the fact that he has less
of a,
because he's white.
Well,
no,
they shouldn't because eventually someone's going to sue over that.
But that comes to that point I was making were you also got to understand where
the stereotype came from,
all those slow fucking white guys.
You know,
I mean,
one of the reasons why I think Dan Marino never won a super bowl was because of
fucking the black lodge brothers.
He had two white corn evacs you can't win a fucking super bowl with two of them,
maybe one.
But I don't think he could win.
I don't think he could win with too.
Right.
Am I nuts?
I remember,
uh,
the,
the comic strip in a,
in a New York City.
I went down there,
I auditioned in 1990.
I went and asked to audition and the guy running the club told me I already have
enough white guys.
And I knew a lot of comedians who got upset like that gone too.
That's fucked up.
He would never say,
I already have enough black guys and soap.
Well first of all,
there's only like at eight black guys working here.
So he wouldn't say that.
And uh,
I,
I understood what he meant.
I knew what he meant.
He meant you better have a fucking point of view because I have enough fucking
suburban white guys that can go on and for 20 minutes be like,
you know,
soap with Bill Clinton,
end table.
I mean,
which end do I put it on once,
you know scribe is stuff is all in the papers.
Yeah,
like he had enough people doing,
I totally understood what he was saying.
He just kind of cut through the fat.
I got enough fucking white comics go in there and do something different or I
have no use for you.
I understood that and the only people who fucking complain,
we're lame ass white comedians.
So what am I saying here?
Am I justify?
I didn't want them fucking say it.
I feel like I'm justifying it here.
I'm not,
I'm not justifying it,
but I also,
I'm just saying you got to tone down the sensitivity here a little bit.
You know?
Right.
Older Asian is not racist as shit.
There's an element of fucking truth to it and there's no hatred in my heart when
I do it.
I just do it for the laugh.
I don't drive around screaming about Asian and old people saying we need to get
them out of the fucking country.
I've added up to hear what their goddamn driving.
They're ruining this country.
They need these old people need to go back to what from where they came from.
Um,
there's another one.
Uh,
so anyways,
built tonight I was watching a TV show and I saw a commercial for the Crisp for
Chris Rock's Broadway show.
They never said the show's name and simply referred to it as the title,
you can't say.
And on the screen,
the second word of the title was black was blackened out and it read the blank
with the hat.
I immediately thought the n word with the hat.
I was also interested in seeing the show.
So I promptly googled it with no results.
I then went to Chris Rock's only to find the title to the show was the
motherfucker with the hat.
I proceeded to laugh and then thought of you and your bid.
Is it racist?
Raise.
So,
uh,
was that racist bill?
I was on the edge,
but generally thought it was funny.
We'd love to hear your thoughts and your girlfriends too.
Well,
a knee is not here right now.
She's mad because of my behavior at the grammys at the Grammy Party.
Uh,
do I think it's racist?
No,
that's what I would've guessed.
You know,
such,
it's such a big deal is made out of that word.
The title.
You can't say Chris always does edgy stuff.
That's what I would have gone with.
You know,
I'm surprised you can't say the motherfucker with the hat at this point.
I watched 60 minutes tonight and Andy Rooney said,
God damn.
And they didn't bleep it out.
So do I think it's racist?
No,
I,
I think I don't,
a lot of people would think it was just because you thought the,
the n word fit in there,
but I,
I maintain this.
Maybe I'm fucking wrong.
You guys can email me,
but I,
I really think it comes,
what's in your heart when you,
when you,
when you're thinking that,
I mean you were just thinking all the word.
You can't say the title.
You can't say.
It's always saying,
you know the end word white people can't say it.
You can't say that.
You know?
So I,
I have no,
I don't think that that's racist and I have the,
and I would have laughed too when I've read that.
That was actually the motherfucker with the hat.
No,
no,
I don't.
All right,
here we go.
Uh,
hey,
here's another one.
Hey,
Bill.
Huge fan of a Pitta Pitta.
Thank you.
Uh,
anyways,
I have,
I have it,
uh,
is,
is it racist question at my job,
I work with the guy who's not really Mexican,
but his father is
what,
so what does that mean?
Because he's not 100% Mexican because he's had that would make him half Mexican,
you know,
what are you saying?
He's like a light beer in the Mexican version of that.
Um,
so anyways,
he's not really Mexican,
but his father is,
uh,
he's from Arizona,
but he looks the type,
I don't get any of that.
So he's half Mexican,
but he looks full on Mexican is that's what,
is that what you're saying?
I don't think this one's going to end good.
I'm going to go on out on a limb here.
Uh,
were okay friends,
but he can be a huge dick sometimes.
It,
occasionally I say something that could be considered racist,
like shut up.
Beaner uh,
but this one time he was working really hard and I just walked by and said,
you people always,
you people always working hard for little wage.
And he was being a huge Dick that day.
Uh,
before I said that,
and he just laughed and we moved on.
My question is,
is it racist to say those type of things if the guys,
if the guys being a complete
jack off and deep down you feel,
you feel like it shows them they're being a dick?
Uh,
yes.
I do think that's racist.
I think if you just said Shit like that is the joke and you guys were friends
and you were fucking around.
It isn't,
but because of the way you're using it,
like when he's being a Dick,
you feel like it,
it,
it shows them that they're being a dick by saying something racist to them.
Yeah.
You're kind of taking it out of the,
uh,
the joke in arena and I'm going to teach this guy a lesson and put him in his
place.
So,
uh,
and plus also you're,
you're fucking kind of naive statements of he's not really Mexican,
but his father is,
but he looks the part.
Yeah.
I'd say I'd be in a,
you know,
in a bar with you and probably a is,
I dunno about 20 minutes in,
you'd say something that I would be like,
you know,
yeah,
I can get,
what did you say?
Could you say that?
Could you repeat that?
You know,
trying to,
with the jukebox noise in the background you have,
but you haven't had that in a fucking bar.
You just hang it out.
Perhaps me all the time on the fucking road.
Back when I was boozing,
I'd be out there and I would just be a,
I'll tell you one of the weirdest ones I ever had.
I did this bit on,
uh,
Jamie Foxx laugh,
a Palooza thing.
Um,
Jamie Fox,
by the way,
who plays my shit all the time on his channel,
on,
uh,
on Sirius Xm,
the foxhole.
I've had more goddamn people come up to me saying,
I heard you on the Fox hole.
I thought you were funny.
That's why I came up to my,
uh,
out to your show.
So thank you to everyone over there.
Um,
but anyways,
so I did this bit and it was a story that happened to me when I was at,
when I was in Nashville,
Tennessee.
I was,
uh,
I was drinking in the bar by myself.
God,
that sounds like such a great fucking idea.
Hundred 20 days in people.
Oh,
does that sound like a good idea of drinking by myself?
And I got damn bar.
I had a couple of fucking years.
Um,
I'm in Nashville,
Tennessee and Terrell Owens,
this is like,
I don't know how many fucking years ago,
but he was doing what he always does.
Starts off good,
but the team then it becomes a total fucking cunt.
So I said,
I said something to effect of,
can you believe this fucking guy?
How much goddamn money do you need to make before you're not a dick?
Like,
what the fuck is wrong with this guy?
And uh,
Oh God,
it's been so long since I remember.
This is the guy,
I'll tell you what the fucking problem is because the guy's a fucking end.
He just dropped the n word
and [inaudible]
I had a fucking know and I immediately was just like,
I immediately though,
how was it?
I immediately looked around,
I was like,
Oh fuck,
I'm going to get fucking some black dude is going to punch this guy in the face
through my head cause I'm standing next to him like I'm going to get fucking,
they're gonna think I'm with this guy.
So that,
that was,
that's right.
This has been a long time since I've told a joke.
That was the joke.
So the joke was basically he dropped the fucking inward.
Uh,
that's right.
He didn't say what the Aa,
he said what the R and he didn't pull up on the yard.
He fucking stuck the landing.
That's how the joke went.
And I felt like,
I just wish there was somewhere I could just act like they wish there was some,
something that I could have done in that moment to immediately say like,
I didn't know this fucking guy.
You know,
I had no idea.
Everything was normal.
We would talking football and out of nowhere he starts with his clan rally
bullshit.
So,
uh,
and I remember too,
like
I didn't roll with what he said and I forget what I said,
but he clearly knew that I was annoyed by him and then he tried to fix it real
quick and try to say like,
I'm not saying they're all like that.
There are some good ones.
And then it was fuck,
it was like a fucking Sitcom.
And then five seconds later some black dude comes walking in,
right?
And then he's like,
Oh hey,
how are you doing?
He's trying to be over-friendly to the guy in some way to make up for the fact
that he dropped the n word to me
and the whole fucking thing was phony.
And then I felt like he was dragging me into it.
And I wanted to say to the guy at that point like,
hey,
why don't you tell that guy some of the shit you were just saying to me five
seconds ago.
You know all that classic shit.
When you think of all the funny stuff you should've said in the moment,
you know,
20 minutes fucking later.
Um,
so anyway,
so I basically,
I turned that into a bit and I did it on the laugh of Palooza thing.
So like three years later I'm in a North Carolina work in this club and a
afterwards I'm standing there and I'm talking to this dude who is like the most
stereotypical redneck guy ever.
You know,
he's talking a lot the edge,
but paper per like if if like if someone from the north did that accent on TV
would be considered like offensive.
That's like how fucking hardcore this guy was.
You know,
you know,
I was all my tractor the other day and I was listening to,
all of my 81 I'm off pigs,
got out his labs are you stuff I could barely catch them.
I mean like telling me stories like that.
Right.
But then he starts talking about my comedy and he was really breaking it down
and just talking about
like in a really intelligent way was breaking thing down.
I was sticking my head like,
this is why I love doing the road,
because you meet all these fucking people.
You have all these preconceived notions.
I'm a fucking looking at this guy.
Like this guy's a God damn hillbilly and here he is breaking down comedy in my
act in particular,
like borderline on the level that a comedian could.
So I was like,
oh,
and this is why I love doing the road.
This is why this is what makes you worldly.
This is how you know it makes you stop thinking ignorant shit,
you know,
which is hilarious.
All the ignorance should I say in my pocket,
whatever.
He makes you less ignorant.
So right
as I'm having that feel good moment thinking about this dude,
I forget what the fuck,
what the fuck happened.
But then out of nowhere he piece said he was telling his story.
Oh,
he actually alluded to the tea actually brought up the joke that I,
the story that I told about being in Nashville and the,
and the guy dropping the n word and he knew why it was funny and he broke that
whole joke down.
He had this really redneck Yat accent,
and I was like,
look at that.
See,
then I'll fucking racist right then I don't know where he starts telling some
fucking story,
trying to make me laugh.
And he got,
and then his punchline,
he'd gotten himself into some sort of predicament.
And then his punchline was,
I was more nervous than an n war.
Then Mike Tice,
no,
I was more nervous than an n word in a,
in a,
uh,
in a spelling bee or something.
He dropped the fucking Edward.
And I remember going,
I just said out loud to myself with the fucking music was so loud.
I was just,
I was just like,
and then that happened.
So
I said to the guy,
I go,
dude,
you just broke down that fucking joke where I talked about somebody doing that.
And then five minutes later you do it.
And he say,
yeah,
I love that joke.
Hey,
like he still didn't get it three times.
I fucking went in trying to explain to him what the fuck just at,
why would you do that?
And just never fucking dawned on him.
Yeah.
And then I,
I just,
uh,
he was talking to me and I just walked away like mid sentence as he [inaudible]
fear and I just fucking walked away.
And uh,
wow.
What else?
Then I went to the other side of the bar and I remember there was these four
chicks were dancing on the bar during the coyote ugly thing.
And one of them was a fat chick who was not sexy but was dancing in a very sexy
way.
And I remember being annoyed at her.
I was really fucking annoyed
that she had the confidence to do that.
I was like,
why your horror,
if you should be off the bar doing setups,
you should
feel shame and you don't.
And I dunno.
Normally that would've made me laugh,
I guess,
but maybe because what the fuck happened over that?
You remember being really annoyed?
Uh,
I don't fucking know.
Do you know I went on,
I had such a fucked up week.
I don't even know what that fat chick just reminded me of something I went to.
I went on a couple's date to a cheesecake factory.
MMM.
And in defense they said,
look,
we don't have to go there,
but you know they got kids and shit.
They just picked something quick and you people know how I feel about the
cheesecake factory.
But I was like,
you know,
I don't give a fuck.
It's better than Apple Bee's.
I'll go over there.
It's,
you know the talking about going in an hour.
So I go over there and I just want to tell you guys something just in case,
just in case you don't know the cheese cake factory fucking sucks.
All right?
It's,
that is horrible food.
Horrific,
horrible fucking food.
And the reason why I'm saying this is because every time I fucking walked by one
of them,
it is jam packed with people.
Line out the fucking door.
Everybody holding those little vibrating things waiting to get called to go into
to to a fucking table,
which is exactly what happened to us.
And I went in there,
I ordered the Kobe beef burger.
I went as high up on the menu as I could and I still felt like I fucking ate a
part of my God damn dresser just sitting in my fucking stomach like a Goddamn
old boot.
Horrible fucking food.
Can you people please stop going to that restaurant?
So he was telling me tonight they don't even advertise on TV.
They don't have to.
People just line up.
They just think it's fucking good.
I like lady Gaga
coming in and that fucking egg from the morgue show.
You know what's going to kill me is,
is when people just going to talk about like how outrageous that was.
You know who thinks like that type of shit is outrageous.
People who found themselves with their hands when they begin to cry.
If you ever seen people like that,
when they start getting emotional,
they fan their face.
What the fuck I'm talking about anymore?
Let's get the youtube videos.
At this point I'm really in a fucking grumpy ass mood.
I had a bad burger this weekend.
I had a fucking flat tire.
Got It.
God Damn Yellow.
Spare goddamn breath mint for a fucking temporary spare.
This is just a miserable fucking podcast.
And I was in a good mood too.
All right.
Youtube videos of the week.
Uh,
NFL trick shot,
white quarterback a check this,
the,
these are all on the Mlm,
podcast.com.
By the way,
I'm this fucking kid's amazing.
You know,
I know a lot of them,
you know.
Okay.
How many attempts did he make to make the fucking throw?
But there's a couple where he does like to three um,
tricks all in one take.
Very impressive.
Um,
but at the end of the video got me fucking hiccups at the end of the video.
Can he read a defense?
Um,
here's another one.
This kid,
uh,
just a,
if you want to see just a great fucking story teller.
Um,
I don't even know what this is the name of the video,
but this is Baltimore storyteller.
The fuck this guy tells a story about a,
Oh,
his dad sent him to the corner store for some bread and he has to get by some
gang bangers.
And this fucking guy I watched like three of his videos is just phenomenally,
just a phenomenal fucking storyteller.
I love telling stories and I let them more I like than listened to a great
storyteller.
This kid's great.
So check that out and check out all those other videos.
A midget wrestler flying.
All right?
If you ever wanted to see a midget in a,
uh,
dressed up like a baby gorilla,
get kicked by a fat bald guy,
I believe the guy's bald.
And then go flying ass over tea kettle in land on another wrestler.
This is the video for you and a funny drum video.
I love this video because the guy's fucking hilarious.
Uh,
English seems to be his third language.
I put that down that high had that.
They had that one,
the one,
two,
three.
Okay.
And the,
and the one told three.
Okay.
That's literally,
that's how this guy fucking gives the,
the drum lesson.
But then he proceeds to play this fucking sick drum groove,
which I still can't fucking play.
Um,
so the guys like awesome.
It's just a far,
it's just like a second or third language.
Um,
oh,
and if you want to see another great wrestling,
just horrific,
the WCW dungeon of doom,
full segment.
I don't know who wrote this shit.
Um,
but it is horrific in a phenomenal fucking way.
Uh,
what else do I go on in here?
Um,
oh,
here's some advice.
Somebody wants a bill.
My girlfriend looks like a centerfold.
Good for you.
She's blind.
She has a beautiful face,
a tiny waists in giant cans.
I have outdone myself.
Well,
what the fuck,
man?
Don't sell yourself short maybe.
Or maybe you're a,
you're a stud.
So he says,
however,
having a girlfriend of such caliber,
as you might imagine,
comes with its share of problems.
Oh,
Jesus.
Here we go.
Like,
uh,
like your good self.
I battle my battle,
keeping my temper under control at times and particularly struggle when my
girlfriend and I go out in public together.
In short,
the amount of male attention she gets is ridiculous.
And at times it's infuriating.
Have you ever found yourself,
uh,
found yourself out with a girl and notice that every man within a three mile
radius from the sweaty 22 year old walking boner to the porky,
sexually frustrated father of three is blatantly staring at her tits in her ass.
Um,
I've always been of the opinion that if a girl is obviously with a guy,
whether you know them or not,
it's a gentleman's code not to have a staring contest with there with her,
with her ring piece.
And what that means.
What's that looking at her pussy.
I have no idea.
This guys from Australia,
um,
if a girl there's a loan or with girlfriends share objectify the shit out of
her.
But I think if a girl is holding hands with their boyfriend and you make it
obvious that your helmet is pressing against the inside of your front Zipper,
then your account,
um,
nothing serious has happened yet,
but the weather is getting warmer,
the outfits are getting smaller and I'm concerned,
I'm gonna wind up with,
I'm going to wind up with some perverts blood and quite possibly come on my
hands all
for now.
Um,
all right.
All right.
This is a tricky situation,
sir.
You know,
it's a very tricky situation.
there's a price you pay for everything.
All right?
You're the one who has the centerfold fucking girlfriend with a great ass and
Nice set of fucking tits and a,
you just,
you just have to
this,
this is,
this is how I look at this shit.
As long as you're,
a woman isn't going around trying to get attention if she's just fucking
standing there and she's so goddamn stunning that men are looking at her,
but you know,
she's not,
Ooh,
I drop my lipstick and then slowly bending over at the waist while looking over
her shoulder.
Um,
if she's doing that,
I can tell you right now a bang or another couple of times and then fucking
dumper because she's going to be an absolute fucking nightmare and a,
and you don't need that in your life,
okay?
But if she's just a stunningly gorgeous woman,
um,
you,
that kind of comes with it.
And,
uh,
if you lose your fucking temper and you start acting like a maniac,
that's a great way to eventually annoy the shit out of her.
And because she can't help it.
Like I said,
if she's not trying to get attention,
she can't help it,
that she's gorgeous.
And uh,
if you then,
it's in this weird way,
you're giving her shit for being herself,
which is not fun for anybody and then you're going to have a problem.
So,
um,
I don't know how to it,
you know what it's like.
It's like a,
it's like when I whore myself out at the end of my shows and I sell DVDs.
All right?
I don't have to do that,
but I choose to do it and I'm standing as a choice.
I fucking made.
And then I stand there and what's going to happen?
I answered this.
Yeah.
This one,
these podcast questions.
Alright.
Eventually somebody is going to come up and they're going to fucking insult me.
Tell me.
They didn't like my act.
Uh,
they didn't think I was as funny as when he saw me on TV and I can't get mad
because it's my fucking fault for standing there like an asshole.
Just,
you know,
I,
I put myself on the dunking store and I got admit sir,
if,
if you're,
if this,
if your girl is the way that you describe her,
you just have to accept that it's,
it's par for the course and uh,
just give yourself a little halftime speech before you go up.
You know,
I'm not going to lose my shit.
Um,
but
okay,
if it is overt,
uh,
there has to be a way that you can fucking address it without pissing her off,
without getting,
you also don't want to get into a fucking fight.
Um,
I dunno.
Just say,
hey buddy,
can you eliminate it to like,
you know,
five seconds shifts of staring at or tea.
I can't say,
uh,
I don't know what you do.
Do that.
That's a rough one.
That's a rough run there,
man.
That takes me back to being,
AH,
Jesus Christ.
I was like 21 years old.
I went on this,
I went out on a date with this girl who was well out of my fucking league just
because I didn't have the confidence to fucking be with her,
you know what I mean?
MMM.
Beautiful Girl.
And I went out with her and I noticed she just kept looking around the
restaurant to see who was looking at her and I remembered it annoyed the shit
out of me,
but I,
I,
I didn't have any experience with beautiful women,
so I just sort of accepted it.
And um,
but I never went out with her again.
It just,
it drove it.
I tapped out somewhere through the fucking dinner,
even back then,
I was an angry son of a bitch.
I was like,
let me get this straight.
I'm buying you fucking dinner and you're looking around to see who's Elsa
staring at your tits.
Um,
yeah,
you're a cunt.
Good looking cunt,
but a cut nonetheless.
Someday those looks are going to be gone and I'm just going to be left with the
content.
You know who's going to be a psycho cunt because you're an attention whore.
And when the attention goes away,
you're going to be like some celebrity who fell off the fucking may have fucked
his bitch.
Fuck this.
You know?
And that was the end of that shit that his podcast is fucking horrific.
Jeez,
I didn't even get going,
man.
You know what it is.
I had a flat tire today and I think that that's,
that's been,
that's a good symbol.
Uh,
this whole podcast,
I've just been riding on the rim.
Ah,
fuck.
I got to start my day tomorrow down at the goddamned dealership is fucking
Douche bags.
They got everything.
It's all wrapped up.
You know,
if you do anything to your Goddamn car,
if I go down to the Goddamn auto zone and I get new wiper blades,
I think that,
I think that cancels out my warranty.
He's fucking cunts.
Um,
so anyways,
this was the lane podcast for this week.
I know it had its moments.
Who's kidding?
Who?
It started off.
Well,
when I was talking about those whaling horse,
um,
I actually had a nice little show biz moment.
A friend of mine got me tickets to,
uh,
um,
the roots do this pre grammy jam where they're just the house band and like
fucking,
I don't know,
20 or 30 of the most legendary insane acts ever.
Just come on stage and start singing songs with them and doing fucking whatever.
And somebody got me a ticket,
uh,
you know,
hanging out,
somehow I got in there and uh,
it was fucking unbelievable.
I think I came home that night and I downloaded like,
probably about $70 worth of music,
just the,
the level of talent that was out there.
And I'm an old guy now,
so I don't know who the fuck,
I don't know who the fuck.
And even Neil was telling me who everybody was,
she was freaking the fuck out.
Oh my God,
that's fucking
Mc.
So,
and I have no of,
I don't know who the fuck they are.
You know what?
I tapped it when they stopped showing videos on MTV.
I kinda like that last wave.
Jay Z,
m and M.
Um,
was there any rock like by then it was all that emo shit.
So I,
I didn't,
I couldn't relate to any of that.
You know what,
what does that fucking goddamn wining song about not giving up?
[inaudible]
they actually play that at sporting events.
It sounds like a man crying.
I don't know.
I know he's saying we will be victorious,
but like just,
it just,
it could have been a better line,
Rick.
You know,
all that shit.
That's when I tapped out all that.
My Chemical Romance.
Uh,
could I have another Kleenex please?
Whatever the fuck name other bands where I just,
uh,
I don't know.
Everybody just sounded like they were crying.
I couldn't handle it.
Your sex is on fire.
That guy fucking clients were all his songs.
How does that fucking song go?
[inaudible] [inaudible]
Rami the cure.
That's how the guy in the cure,
he used to sing
oh ways.
Love
you.
Oh,
um,
yeah.
I'm not into that shit.
I'm sorry.
Was that,
there was an annoying,
was that as annoying as it just sounded in my fucking is what?
That music is fucking annoying.
So I didn't know who anybody was,
but uh,
you know,
it was amazing.
Was Booker t came out.
What didn't even from booker t and the mgs,
I didn't even know the fucking dude was still alive and it was such like a Paris
Hilton air.
My Guy Am I god,
that's hot kind of fucking crowd that uh,
that they had no fucking idea who the guy was.
Uh,
my favorite performer of the night was a chuck Brown came out and sang,
busting loose,
and he was the shit.
He came out on a leather on leather fucking outfit with the fucking pimp hat.
He sang the shit out of the song with the roots in the background and the roots
of fucking unbelievable.
And for guitarists out there,
everybody knows quests as shit,
but I'll underrated Kirk Douglas,
dear fucking guitarist.
That dude is fucking insane.
I'm talking John,
the ground level plant,
they just fucking,
everybody in that band is just,
it's,
they're insane.
And a fortunate,
we was sitting close enough that [inaudible] I was just awesome.
Like,
you know me,
I'm like a fucking geek for that shit.
Like I wish I could be a f if I didn't do this.
I wish I could be a,
so I like,
I think like anybody,
you can do that stuff as I've trashed half the people on the grammys,
you know what I'm saying?
But like musicians,
people who play instruments,
I'm absolutely fucking blown away by him.
And just being close enough to watch somebody take a solo and just,
you can just see just going off the top of,
they just feeling it and just doing it and coming out of it.
And then just fucking looking back at the drummer like,
all right,
let's,
let's go back into this next part of it.
And everybody seamlessly goes into it.
You know,
anybody who's ever played like a fucking garage band,
you know,
and just,
had the courage to make a tape and you hear how fucking awful you are.
They actually hear live music and they played for like three fucking hours.
I ended up leaving.
I was so god damn old.
Like I'm at the age now where if I stand up too long,
my back hurts.
Like my lower fucking back,
my feet hurt.
It's,
it's fuck is terrible.
I've got to come home.
And sit in a Goddamn Tabla,
Epson salt.
But anyways,
uh,
I downloaded a bunch of Chuck Brown Shit,
a couple other rappers I downloaded.
I don't have my iTunes open right now.
I don't even,
I don't know who the fuck they were.
Uh,
but it's kind of funny rappers now.
They have that odd thing where they,
they're wearing skinny tight jeans,
which I never thought would come back into style again yet.
They're still hanging off their fucking ass,
which drives me up the Goddamn wall.
Fuck.
Pull them up.
Um,
anyways,
that's the podcast for this week.
Oh,
I am going to be in,
I have to a magnificent theater dates this,
uh,
this this fucking week because I'm a God damn big shot.
Let me see if I can open my website here and let you know where the hell these
things are.
This really isn't even technically the podcasts anymore.
This is just the outtakes.
Um,
I am going to be at the Tarrytown music hall in Tarrytown,
New York,
and it's February 17th,
which is a Thursday.
Friday,
I'm going to be at the count Basie theater in Red Bank,
New Jersey.
So come one,
come all.
I have a brand new hour,
his shit and I got a new killer fucking 15 minutes,
then I'm absolutely loving.
And every time I do it,
it becomes a couple more minutes.
You know,
one of those bits started with like four minutes.
I just keep fucking elaborating and uh,
uh,
planning on having a great time.
So,
uh,
I hope all you guys can come out to that,
for people who live in Florida,
um,
people always talking about that.
Oh yeah.
I got some fucking gigs here,
man.
Places I don't usually play.
I have,
I'm playing the new World Symphony and um,
symphony symphony theater on the 4th of March,
Miami Beach,
Florida,
the tower theater in Philadelphia on April 9th and the day,
either the day before that or the day after that,
I just added a date in Maryland.
I'm going to put the date up,
uh,
tomorrow,
when it gets all solidified.
And,
uh,
oh,
actually outside of,
yeah,
outside of Baltimore,
I have a Gig.
And,
uh,
the PAPP's theater in Milwaukee,
Wisconsin on April 22nd,
April 23rd and at the Royal Oak Music Theater in Detroit,
Michigan.
And,
uh,
also I added,
um,
I just put another date up.
Um,
Jimmy Norton's,
uh,
antisocial tour,
the Miami Heat of comedy shows.
It's a stars,
uh,
Jimmy Norton,
Jim Brewer,
David tell and myself.
And we're going to be at the Foxwoods casino and Masha Takata,
Connecticut on,
uh,
April 30th,
um,
anybody in the New England area,
uh,
tristate area.
You got to come up for that one.
I'm going to tell you right now.
Uh,
I worked with those guys.
They're fucking,
all of them are at the top of their fucking game.
And I'm telling you,
we did three shows when I was in Atlantic City and you know,
you know it as Comedians,
we don't watch stand up.
We just don't after a while.
But I stood on the side wall,
watched all of them.
Um,
I just,
it just,
they fucking phenomenal.
So please come out to those shows.
That's it.
That's the podcast for this week.
You guys all have a good week.
Uh,
I don't know what else to tell you.
I fuck,
I forgot to talk about the Bruins Canadians game.
Did you see that with all the old school fighting in the goal scoring was like
fucking 27 to 26,
I think was the final score with all the fighting.
And I want to know Montreal Canadian.
What the fuck happened?
He had team,
I'm not giving you shit about losing a game was the only one fucking game.
But I mean,
you guys always had a tough guy all the way back to fucking John Cortex.
Chris Nilan,
George Larocque.
You had,
that guy was the toughest guy in the league.
Why did you guys,
all you had was,
you know,
I know the Bruins kicked the shit out of you guys,
but I'm not an idiot.
We,
we,
we beat up a bunch of gold scores.
I felt bad for that last guy,
Jesus Christ.
He took like 20 upper cuts to the face and somehow ended up with two giant paper
cuts.
Um,
Google it,
man.
And maybe I'll have that youtube video also on the [inaudible] podcast.com.
Uh,
but I'm telling you right now,
if you're a fan of fighting and hockey watched the game on March 8th when the
Bruins and the Canadians play again,
because I'm a tell you right now that Canadians are not going to sit back and
take that fucking physical ass kicking that they took.
I and I can,
I can't wait to see the absolute fucking animals that they're going to bring up
for that game.
You know,
whatever has a lower
beyond thunder bay is what I'm guessing what they're going to bring up.
Just like some old school fucking guy,
one of those white guys who has like an afro in a porno mustache.
I'm thinking I'm going to bring up a couple of those guys and it's going to be,
it's going to be fucking insane.
I hope it is.
I hope it doesn't fucking not live up to the hype.
Um,
all right.
That's it.
I'm done.
Okay.
I've had a long fucking day.
All right.
And I apologize to anybody out there who aspires to be a whaling whore at the
grammys.
You know,
I'm just,
you know,
I'm not saying that those,
those whaling whores,
they're not whores,
but you know,
I,
I don't underst I fucking don't understand that kind of singing.
It's,
you're not singing,
you're wailing.
All right.
Just seeing the fucking song,
you know,
and then,
and then fucking what's her face?
Lil Booze,
booze face there.
She always gets that son in a voice.
No,
ugh.
She got that pasty bloated boost face.
And then just in case you miss it,
she puts that red lipstick in the,
in the,
in the middle.
Don't you just want to grab Christina by both a big Java [inaudible] you know,
she got a man's haircut.
She could do like the Winston Churchill Story.
I've been,
I've actually,
this is just,
this is totally like extra time on doing,
on the podcast to try and get something funny in this fucking thing this week.
I noticed the other day,
um,
you know,
to,
to people who really look alike is Richard Simmons and the lead singer of the
Scorpions.
You notice that they have the exact same awful fucking hair.
They're going bald in the exact same fucking way.
You know that I just do an awful fucking eighties joke.
Were they separated at birth?
Have you ever seen them together?
Oh,
Bill.
Quit by your fucking behind.
All right.
This is it.
How long can you guys still listen to this shit?
How long are you going to sit there and torture yourself?
This is like a comedian does not get off the fucking stage as people look slowly
walking out of the Goddamn club.
I'm still here.
How empty or your lives shut it off?
Um,
oh fuck.
You know what?
I forgot to play.
I asked somebody
from England to,
to,
I wanted to hear a cozy smug cuts in the English accent.
Here goes,
you want to hear it?
Here it is.
This is all the way from my fucking people over and ing.
Hang on.
What the fuck just happened there?
I'm going to play it again.
Here comes
Cousey smug.
Can't every,
a couple of like cozy smug cunts.
Fucking love that.
Um,
alright.
There you go.
That's the podcast for this week.
I apologize for the meandering.
I apologize this from,
for my excuses.
I went real Peyton manning this week,
didn't I?
We are protection issues.
I had a flat tire,
you know,
that was a real bitch this week.
Um,
whatever.
I'll make it up next week.
Okay?
They can't all be gems.
All right?
Everybody has a bad fucking day.
Take it out on me.
I apologize to all the whaling whores out there.
I said that.
All right?
I don't know how to get off stage this week.
That's it.
Have a great fucking weak.
Go fuck yourselves.
Don't take any shit.
Talk to you next Monday.
[inaudible].